welcome back to julienne podcast yeah we
talked with you guys about the Jenna and
Jillian things and so many other things
Wang thank you for joining us this week
this episode is brought to you by boom
branch the lovely creators of this
blanket right here yeah well a branch
has all of your sheet bedding any sort
of thing in that arena needs its luxury
bedding for affordable prices check it
out at bowl and branch comm enter
product code Jenna Julian at checkout
you get 20% off and free shipping thank
you to bowl and branch our other sponsor
this week is me undies
when Valentine's Day this year guys get
them some me undies they're the sexiest
hottest underwear around right now
softest material we know from experience
check it out at me undies comm slash
Jenna Julian you get 20% off and then
you're going to be wearing sexy
underwear so it's a win-win
and you'd hear Jenna make that promise
so it's a win-win I was looking through
some of our podcasts on the channel
recently and like five in a row start
with dink dink yeah I love it I think
it's funny when we go through them and
then we're just sitting there doing that
pretty good it's pretty funny we get
kind of [ __ ] younger thank thank
thank thank dank I'm thinking about
getting them a green screen for the
podcast so yeah well basically just put
it right here and you can't see anything
good one you checked us know if you guys
have any suggestions I know that you
know like professional talk shows and
podcasts things have them and I would
only want them to make it look more
exciting than the sound foam if you have
ideas leave in the comments I guess
tweet it - whatever but I probably will
get one regardless because we could use
it for many other things but it would be
nice to have a green screen on the
podcast true I'll be fun don't you be
underwater be fun we could man
we could be in an underwater desert
that's true we could be everywhere the
coolest what are we doing well we've had
a couple podcasts I believe recently
that have been less happy and fun and
more kind of serious talking to you
that's what we figured b.pepper in a
nice little fun way
I feel pepper and fresh ground pepper
we're gonna play a game I didn't invent
this I found it actually on the
subreddit ask reddit now I didn't look
at the thread because I didn't want any
ideas to be spoiled for me but the
thread was like what shitty description
can you give of a movie like [ __ ] very
shitty in short of a description to
describe a movie and so I thought if we
could come up with descriptions for
movies in that manner like really shitty
in short the other person has to guess
what movie were describing so I thought
that would be really funny idea so we
just spent some time brainstorming and
writing things down so I'm drawing each
have a good amount of shitty
descriptions of movies and we're going
to read them off and see if we can guess
each other's I'm descriptions I didn't
realize that you got this off a reddit
thread now after this I want to go read
that reddit thread after we're done yeah
I didn't want to look at it first
because I don't know I know because then
it ruins yeah um so that's that is what
we're some of these i trolled pretty
hard yeah me too and and like if I
describe a movie or something and I say
something it may not be how I think of
it it's more just like being funny yeah
we there were no rules that we control
as hard as we bought no rules so I say I
say we go one one okay you go first okay
right well you got [ __ ] first movie plot
really and I started off with a troll
bang
so whatever dad he touches it gets lost
make friends I love you dad the end
whatever that he touches it yes makes
friends I feel like this is some sort of
like fairytale movie retouches something
and then turns into something or gets
into a different world whatever dad he
touches it
how sunglass take Todd Oh mug we can do
a time when you really good can you read
again yeah that would even do it on time
River go um yeah hold on I can only do
so many things my phone at once your mum
watch or something whatever dad he
touches it gets lost makes friends I
love you dad the end
[ __ ] alright really we got a lot of
these to go through a come on we should
I do the timer how long what was
guessing has to do the timer okay was it
30 seconds do you want a clue yeah if
you focus on he touches it whatever dad
what does he touch and why does he make
friends after he touches it touched Oh
Finding Nemo yeah it makes friends oh
that's good I liked whatever dad that's
good that's a good thing okay you chain
um you have to get your stopwatch ready
alright let's just do it on like a
charger system like around 30 seconds
yeah all right you guys let us know okay
we'll listen to you guys alright ready
mm-hmm
guy has had it with all of the robot
[ __ ] goes apeshit realizes he's a robot
the iRobot yeah that's pretty easy I
mean there's the word robot like five
times yeah anyway nice spoiler do this
well yet none of you first of all here's
your new so we don't have to say spoiler
but we're gonna be nice and say it
anyway
spoiler alert for all of the moves we're
about to do yeah um right you ready yeah
go okay I don't haven't heard from you
in a while you're getting married
[ __ ] that steals a bread truck okay get
married at the end that's friend's
wedding yeah I knew you're gonna do one
steals a bread truck
you love that foggy can you explain in
like a very short amount of time why you
love that movie cuz I I found nothing in
it I got nothing from that movie
it pissed me off that's not true you
liked it at the end ah spoiler alert she
doesn't end up with the guy I think I
was being nice I like that outcome
because the other outcome would have
just made me throw my computer at the
wall because the other outcome would
have just been debauchery you said you
liked it when you watch
I like the parts of it I think the whole
movie Wow
could use a lot of work why is it good I
don't know to me it's like a classic I
just like it like you described you
described it I was like it's such a
classic like love story but like really
it's like it's not I like it no I'm
saying to me it's a clap not a classic
love story for me it's Anna classic
movies I'm not trying to brag they
remove a dress it's a very like 90s
movie you know I think I just had a
really really different expectation
coming into it than the pond [ __ ]
best friend's wedding what did you
expect a chick a chick I expected a girl
and her girl best friend to be getting
married in it's just like all about that
drum I did do you think it was about I
die or still love also just because it's
a move oh don't you do chicks don't you
dare kidding ah ah drama okay
you best friends are have the same
gender sounds like a you problem okay
hey wait that shallow ass dude is really
gonna wake up and do this [ __ ] every day
shall oh hell no Groundhog Day no but
you're getting there
emphasis on everyday what that shallow
guy well yeah what wait that shallow ass
dude is gonna wake up and do this [ __ ]
every single day and that's but it just
ends in a question that's that's my
description of the movie that's what I'm
left with mmm I don't know it's too
vague for me 50 first dates Adam Sandler
is like the most shallow [ __ ] guy and
then he meets this girl and he's just
gonna be like Prince Charming every
single day for the rest was somehow like
a plot summary yeah of course all right
enough some of mine are pretty like
intentional you guys like that one I
guess I haven't really like watched it
all the way through you never watched
with you first I don't remember it was
on TV recently that's the most you yeah
that's the most that's the problem here
I feel like a couple of mine you haven't
seen but [ __ ] it I'm gonna do anyway
fine okay you ready for this one yeah
I'm ready I was born rude okay making
shoes holy [ __ ] I'm a new person
kills a guy makes more shoes the end
wait is this the cobbler yes don't you
guys dare ask why we know what the
cobbler is you say we're about to go
kill the guy worse my movie is primo
Julian kept asking if we could turn it
off and I said no I wanted to stick it
out well we made it so far I'm so glad
we stuck because we had read it was like
the worst movie I gained so much from
how much I lost watching a movie quote
me on that okay I actually don't know if
you've seen this movie but I know you
know that I've seen this movie and I
think I've seen parts of it yeah dorky
dad gets cheated on learns how to dress
well and becomes gigolo 97 percent of
the movie takes place in a bar deuce
Bigalow male gigolo mmm makeover me I
don't know what that is but now hmm okay
I don't know you just made the sound
that you make when you're gonna get
enemy it is recanting hmm ah Crazy
Stupid Love oh yeah Oh Steve Carrell
okay hey and that whole movie is
basically shot in a bar hmm they live in
that bar except for Ryan Gosling when he
takes his shirt off yeah that's one
scene getname literally any other scene
they're in tonight I'm just kidding it's
not that blatant but they're in the bar
a lot hmm
I've food on my hand I just realized you
should eat it yeah it's not safe earlier
all right you ready yeah buddy yeah such
a troll guy that loves mayonnaise
sandwiches leaves home and vet stuff
gets rich falls in love writes a million
checks
days rich because his family family
invested in coffee beans at the end whoa
many sandwiches hmm thought I was only
one the life mayonnaise sandwiches no
the only thing I can think of when I
hear many sandwiches is um now I can't
forget I can't remember that name and
that movie [ __ ] um can I hear overtime
guy that loves mayonnaise sandwiches
leaves home invents stuff gets rich
falls in love writes a million checks oh
I forgot I deleted it goes broke but
then he stays rich because this family
invested in coffee beans to the end I
have no idea do I mmm-hmm no can't dance
can you just say it the jerk oh the jerk
uh yeah I only watch that once I needed
to watch it more like how that David
movie no it's good movie
oh yeah jamort uh hey I don't know fail
at you yes right because that was a lot
even right the scene when she his mom
gives him that no that's I'm saying I
seen it once I can't recall scenes like
that you go use a phase of mayonnaise
sandwich and I wrapped it in cellophane
just like how do you like the movies
[ __ ] touch pottery it's good I was
raised a poor black child there's a lot
of gems in that movie um but I need to
watch it again to be able to okay put a
balloon in your mouth do you have a
balloon oh no I don't wait yes I do he
pulls it out no none of this new none of
this old wine I want some fresh way
that's fun ever that's right never ever
that's funny okay good okay um a
breadbox sized machine has more
personality than the entire human race
oh yeah that's good right away is that
easy
Wow Wow no it was good huh I did I
didn't want to watch that at all until
Julian for I forced you to watch that
and you were
so happy that I did that's one of my
favorite Pixar - yeah the cutest okay
this one is intentionally vague with and
trollee okay you ready yeah I'm ready
okay a couple of weirdos like each other
and do a dance about it the end Dumb and
Dumber mm-hmm couple of weirdos like
each other and do it dance about it do
want a hit
yes this is another movie that you
forced me to watch really mm-hmm you
took me to the movies to see it
I did well we've only been in the movies
like twice [ __ ] through another hint hmm
maybe a hint I'm pretty sure what
two-face won an Oscar from this movie Oh
oh I love this movie silver linings
playbook yes yes we saw that in
theorists Wow good job Julie and that is
a great choice this is a really great
movie a little weirdos like each other
and do a date I love a couple of
weirdoes that's pretty good okay this
one's pretty easy okay
guy tries adderall whole world gets
wrecked by him limitless I don't see not
me
you don't need to write like when they
started putting commercials out for it
you're like okay so that are all
documentary [ __ ] cocaine speed like
we get it I think you're making a show
and Adderall heard nothing limitless
show oh we're just getting turning you a
TV show I've seen it you might not get
this cuz I don't know if you've seen
this movie but whatever we'll try we
grew up together and kissed one time but
then I get like stung by a bee or
something and died the end what the [ __ ]
if you don't know someone has died
getting stung by a bee or something like
that
I can't completely 100
remember what umm-hmm soon will be my
girls no okay well that's what it was
that's my girl that's the name oh yeah I
was gonna guess that yeah you should
have gotten it from stung by bees I was
gonna get my boy hmm
but never mind girl okay got stung by a
bee or something I don't know I can't
remember the end okay okay guy has
tattoo addiction behaves like it's not
the only addiction he has momentum he's
constantly like passed out waked that's
not the movie yes but it's a joke it's a
shitty description by his tattoo
addiction you understand like this is of
an idiot watch the movie and gave a
sentence to describe it it looks like he
has a tattoo addiction and he's
constantly passed out so it's like he
probably has other addictions oh I was
making like charlie like riddles like
okay that that it's not a real but it's
a shitty that's the epitome of a shitty
movie description and I love memento
because it's a great movie everybody
showed it to me so I made Julianne watch
that you're showing today you're welcome
all right you ready you hear the rear
making it right no yeah that's right
it's gonna suck how did I know right
okay
vrooom crime some people died room crime
yeah yeah room crime some people die
let's move to Mexico okay fast and
furious yeah I was good good shake
that's good one that was a good one is
you get oh wow good Todd hmm it was it
was an okay coffee you know it could've
gone either a good idea it could have
more depth to it and then flow at the
end but it kind of just like this little
it was like a bad signal cop mm-hmm
husband hates wife wife hates husband
wife frames him husband still looks like
the shitty one Conger yeah I don't get
it husband still looks like the oh okay
right yeah sounds gonna be everything
when Jenna didn't like it as much
yeah no everyone was like oh this
[ __ ] movie yeah I mean I and I wasn't
on that train I didn't think it was like
amazing I just liked it that was good
movie
hmm but yeah I was over height I agree I
also just know too many people that way
over hyped movies to you and then so you
like go into it thinking it's gonna be
great and then you're like oh yeah
that's that person that talking way over
hyped movies yeah my best buddy who I
was high school with um I would see
movies with him pretty often in high
school he goes he moves pretty regularly
and every single time he saw a movie you
know we would look each other and I'd be
like what you think of you like oh good
and I'd be like yeah it was good and
that was how it was every single time
like messy time yeah we were just like
oh it was a good movie of course it was
it was a money's nice and then I started
meeting people who were like mmm this
movie was horrible and I'm like wait
that movie it was great I always just
had that like it was a good movie you
know yeah it was good why would I not
like it that's really cute yeah I guess
you never like saw movie that hit you
right in that hate spot yeah that's not
how this works I mean at least it's not
how any of this works yeah anyways okay
this one's pretty vague to really
rollerblading at the mall applying
skills from other sports get a coach
maybe blow the coach that's not part of
it I just wrote that tone okay sparkling
high five the end party doctor yeah what
would you cut out door glady buffing
with John that's the general description
of my
shoulda left it in um no I don't know
okay um guy chooses hobbies over sex
gets mocked up work forty year old
virgin yeah oh and now I'm gonna make
your blue pants blazing ya really wanted
egg salad sandwich so I went hard II got
all the eggs and you know by the time I
was done make it I didn't even want you
what I do with all the same size uh such
a good news good movie okay
my parents forgot me I messed with a
couple of dudes my parents had to move
the end come on
yes remember that scene where he's
hiding under the blanket yes that would
have been like such a better scene if it
was a bowl and branch blanket so much
more comfortable living warmer it would
have been softer he would have been more
at ease he would have pulled probably
better pranks and you could add ball and
branch sheets in blankets right now
let's go to Berlin branch comm check out
their selection they have some of the
most luxurious bedding pieces you can
ever find for great prices and you know
they have 30 days risk risk free trial
you can try their stuff out for 30 days
you don't like it set it back you get
all your money back
but we can tell you from experience
falling branch makes incredible sheets
bedding all sorts of stuff this we fight
over this in the living room until when
we watching like TV and stuff we leave
in the living room when we fight over it
yeah because it's soft and light and
also warm yeah you know I just have to
say that that was some of your finest
work thank you very much I was really
top-notch Jillian thank you
I was concerned about this podcast
because it's so fast-paced I didn't know
I was gonna do that but figured it out
so you found a way you sure did check
out Boland branch right now if you are
interested in sleeping tight and getting
great night's leaves and being
comfortable and having awesome bed and
going to Bowlin branch com enter product
code Jenna Julian at checkout 20
free shipping 30-day free trial thank
you bowling branch also win Valentine's
Day
get yourself get your significant other
get your best friend who might want to
be your significant other sometime some
awesome micro modal underwear that's
what they call their fabric it is twice
and sauces cotton its yeah this is
appropriate actually and it has birds
like in the mail this is actually the
theme song for me at ease
they have incredible designs that would
make you want to walk everywhere around
your house and maybe outside of your
house that's appropriate in your
underwear
so check out me undies calm right now
slap me a nice calm slash Jenna Julian
get 20% off free shipping when
Valentine's Day guys win it your
significant other or your friend who
could be your significant other weights
up on Valentine's Day and opens up some
leondis doesn't have to be for your
boyfriend or your girlfriend it can be
through of any gender before your
relationship status or any religion or
when it could be for your art from your
uncle but you buy alright well that's it
weakens about where we go like a sexy
time and your sexy underwear
thank you me undies I think you just
thank them enough with making them an
original song like that Thank You Polly
brave ticka ticka ticka Bam Bam Bam and
both of them are done sponsoring me and
forever done and you know they're not
done with you they're done with me
personally aw its package deal nope we
sponsored the Milton and Julian podcast
remember audible good audible.com slash
Jenna
remember when we tell ya
um I'll just do clear articles not
sponsoring us this week me DS - alright
higher let's move on woody yeah woody
grant okay
I'll sing that song for you when it's
your turn okay ready okay not yeah okay
oh this is Charlie there we go we should
leave no we should stay we have to leave
then we walk around sorry no your eyes
comfortable it's okay we just move it
back no I like talking into it like I'm
in [ __ ] whatever
what are you in [ __ ] PR oh well if
we're gonna do what is it clunky in Hey
s voice modulation or some Julius ASM hi
ster we were into a whole podcast nice
yeah okay do you want to hear it yeah
I'm waiting we should leave no we should
say we have to leave and we walk around
and jump off a cliff with a stranger the
end hmm here I'll change it for you
yeah I want to leave no we have to stay
this is where we live but there's a
whole world out there ah something
happens were forced to leave how we find
a stranger and he has an animal for a
belt and then we jump off a cliff with
him it's still too vague he has an
animal for a belt an animal for a belt
so as a snake
it's name is belt oh oh oh we just watch
this it's a Disney movie dealt its
Croods yeah [ __ ] cruise is a great
movie I'm put that movie to cruise
temporal um Oh fun fact every time we
see Jenna's mom we always go like that I
hand up this isn't it there we go
ruled she does it back to us and one
time we did it in the airport but
her mama's higher and doesn't he's like
saw across security and we were like
Debbie to cruise and she was like tires
if she went like this but it looks okay
for those of you they can't see what
we're doing or haven't seen the Croods
they're holding their hands just hand
open like like they're talking of your
son right over their head just like
you're raising your hand so we were
doing that to my mom in the airport
because we saw her she was like getting
farther ahead of us in the security line
in a crowded [ __ ] airport he held her
hand straight up in the air and she
looks over at us and it looks like she's
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] manasa Nazi [ __ ]
toss yeah it's like we started crying
laughing because at first we later Chris
did you can't like Yeller
whatever is because not hear us oh my
god put your [ __ ] yeah okay most what
that was very funny that was ridiculous
Wow out of the Debbie Machine the Debbie
machine okay go alright um guide mrs.
kids cross dresses for fun but finds
other uses for it hmm this is Delta yeah
you over modulate when you do that
that's why I was trying to yeah it's
making them on come alright this is the
[ __ ] Doubtfire yeah I was easy it was
easy okay ready yeah somebody make me a
human nobody makes me a human makes own
human makes a friend and a boyfriend
also the end somebody make me tie story
make me a hero like turn me into a human
or make me a human make me a human I
want a human what a small human oh wait
okay read it again read it again
somebody's baby mama yeah I was thinking
Indian in the cupboard but then I was
like
simply baby mama although I've
previously makes those two films out
before me true don't we all happens to
the best of us right ready
that was a good dance yes I'm ready
superheroes flaunt powers and get upset
when whole city gets sick of their [ __ ]
go fight crime on some Island is this
the movie that I've seen I think so if
you have Excel yeah if you haven't we're
gonna have some problems like Fantastic
Four or like um what she wanna rephrase
it yeah okay
superhero family foreign power family
The Incredibles
oh that's like one of your favorite
movies I know they're making a second
one I couldn't be more excited actually
I could but that only will happen when
it's closer to the movie release then
I'll be more excited so I shouldn't say
I couldn't be more excited I should say
I will at some point be more excited but
right now I'm at my maximum capacity of
excitement that I could be at this
moment true mmm good description true
true was it like some kid in high school
I tweeted it two chains and sadly this
girl said she'll go to prom with me if I
score a touchdown at the ball game what
do I do
and he says score two touchdowns and
dump er true oh my god Wow okay yeah
okay I the gambling problem forces child
to gamble for him dies still goes to
heaven the end force this child to go to
heaven for him no no no to dr. gamble
for him and then he dies and goes to
heaven yeah so you see him in heaven
mm-hmm weird I have a gambling problem
don't focus on that that's not gonna
help you focus on still goes to heaven
right hittin this character is not a
human what
not human he's an animal mm-hmm don't
make that face a me talking to make that
face it still goes to heaven ha ha like
when you think about that he's just like
a shitty [ __ ] dog man and he like
Gamble's and then he's gets ready to do
is so funny makes that little girl
gamble for him yeah that movies very
funky like I watched it with you you
showed whoa this is way worse than I
remember and like even things like the
audio levels like you can't hear their
voices in some scenes it's like mixed
babbling I loved it like you're like
dialog sometimes it's very confusing but
yeah no I understand me I love that
movie
okay an exciting story of the even more
boring part of baseball like that uh
women's baseball shuffle is the eve is
like a softball was the boring part of
it no that's not what it is so insane
again an exciting story of the even more
boring part of baseball mmm Moneyball
yeah and it could go either way if I
said an exciting story of the even more
boring part of football that's your
favorite movie Dennis Quaid I think yeah
I this doesn't sound like it's your
favorite movie
we never training day no draft day Jenna
hate birthdays he's never even seen it
so that was like you could not [ __ ]
pay me all the money in the world to go
watch that nothing against him no Jose
Eddins crazy I think so yeah that's your
favorite movie you should know that Oh
[ __ ] oh and I don't [ __ ] care
yeah you should puppy care okay Julianne
you will appreciate that okay what you
got I think point zero zero zero zero
zero zero one percent of the population
will also appreciate this because I'm
pretty sure it's for you
my point has seen it ready somebody in
this elevator is the devil the end devil
yes oh my goodness you still have that
[ __ ] DVD and never returned it
I rented that from Blockbuster and never
gave it back Julien rented it from
Blockbuster this is bright we presided
we moved into this house and I was like
join us this devil ah it's a prized
possession and I'd I don't want to get
raided it means a lot to me it holds
value in my heart I watched it once and
didn't like it I like I like the DVD I
like the fact that I have this M night
Shyamalan movie about a devil in an Lda
and we watch the whole thing we did I
liked it I liked to the time it was more
than just like Charlie it was like a
date night movie ah
but yeah that was a good one because
somebody in this elevator is the devil
yeah okay family is missing daughter dad
makes looking for her all about his
badass self take it yeah what's that
noise probably me yes you're stopping me
I like it I don't and I think they don't
I dance okay you guys one now if you
want to hear my leg slowly go under this
is not live oh wait you guys alive right
press my my life you know their lives
we're calling me dead I'm alive who
wouldn't think that's just the soothing
sound
it's just imagine that it's a beach wave
I don't want to imagine anything I'll
just D let's just do that cuz you're not
gonna stop it's like the beach since all
that sounds like a beach and then in
Reverse
like you were whining the beach oh my
guess is fun is [ __ ] okay you ready yeah
lit okay such a troll oh yeah like we
were in the other room sitting there
like poles we're just done wrapping
ourselves up you were cracking ourselves
up yeah okay tell me a story I like this
story I can't remember anything
stay with me okay tell me your story I
like this story I hear remember anything
gets stabbed with a sedative both died
at the end oh my god get stabbed with
his sedative oh my god that's so died
thank you okay wait
I can't remember this I can't remember
anything is always this tell me a story
I like this story I can't remember
anything get stabbed with a sedative
both died the end kind of a hint mmm
yeah there's a whole movie in between
everything I just described to you hmm
it's a love story the notebook
yeah is it God tell me a story I like
this story Oh cuz it's the game for
telling the story to the kids
stabbed through the sedative both died
my god the end that's horrible
tap dish I'm a terrible person you know
what I like that because it's a it's an
interesting it's a interesting take on
an otherwise romantic movie you're
welcome what I do
I appreciate that thanks Gillian second
base with pastries American Pie yeah
that was easy
third base oh it's Paul he put a [ __ ]
dick yeah but it starts with second base
okay
second base comes before third base have
you ever heard of softball that's how it
works do you know where the softball is
what's second base do second base to me
was like someone feeling you up oh yeah
no that's that's different
what's yours so good look it like the
hands doing the work is second base yeah
then what's third days I'm not doing the
work see you it's so we're do you think
you got it okay
comment below what second base and what
third base is for you guys I have no
idea that we had different bases what
are you telling me that I have [ __ ]
five this whole time oh my god no it
goes first base is kissing second base
is like feeling you up like you feel
them up while you kiss them that's part
of first base but taking on taking a
lead off first base you're about to
steal a second the taking a lead is just
like ground now third base is like
anything genitals basically the home
base is like anything yes yes that's my
new band name anything genitals welcome
because my name is Jenna I'm the lead
singer genitalia
oh um yeah all right so comment below am
i right or is she I think I think this
is an age thing happening he's probably
an age thing yeah I think everyone who
is close to my age is going to say what
I say and I'm not believe that you drop
the bombshell on me that we do not
understand the basis I don't think we've
ever said base before in that context
how many ballplayers does it take to
figure out what the base is on my right
up top oh yeah oh yeah yeah who's on
first base gone sexual sexual okay right
Wow enough of that
[ __ ] your turn because this whole
started with America but this one is so
vague and trolly that you should demand
a better explanation when I'm done gets
knocked unconscious has a cool dream
wakes up the end okay
get do you want to hit yeah okay she
gets knocked unconscious really no I
baby uh-huh
in a twister has a cool dream wakes up
the end Wizard of Oz yeah entra Lytro
yeah okay in order to [ __ ] his brother
needs to be right next to him oh my god
stepbrothers I don't [ __ ] know know
what in order to [ __ ] his brother needs
to be right next to him you know I'm
talking about
no I really don't I'm talking to them
you don't know anything in order to
focus on his brother needs to be right
next to him oh is that that [ __ ]
conjoined twins movie what what's it
called Matt Damon okay can you stuck on
you that's disgusting
there's a scene there's Tuesday night
each other though they probably share a
[ __ ] penis their color conjoined at
like the liver okay they're not sharing
a penis I just like you basically see
one of them in the shower that I check
and then one of them better than a
chicken the other ones just like reading
the newspaper mm-hmm they're really
cooperative anyways okay I'm I'm try
started trolling pretty hard around here
all right okay we don't even like you
you're not even our kid [ __ ] you guys
peace out
becomes most important person in a
subculture of all time the end
Wow sounds a good story I don't know
what that is though all right what if I
phrase it this way get back under the
stairs kid slave Harry Potter
God think [ __ ] you guys peace out
becomes the most important person in a
subculture of all time
wow that's good Harry Potter hey you
darn your thorn yeah um pret there's
this one part where he jumps 20 meters
in the air forward off of his car moving
a hundred miles an hour
is not a summary of the movie okay you
know what you didn't listen you didn't
no no I want to clear this up you didn't
listen I said we're doing shitty
descriptions of movies and you took it
as a summary okay so we're doing
different things here yeah you're right
I'm not the wrong one
you're right No okay okay okay ready
yeah
you can't do that you're a rat does it
does it Oh funny you can't do I imagine
the sunglasses dropping on his face does
it
they were narrow near deal with it
working at the shitty amusement park
drives man to cheat on his wife um
eventually yeah is that it yeah I
Reynolds you've ever seen that yeah yeah
you have of course you want time oh I
just blacked it out because it was not
for me it was a good movie
not very good I don't ask for than that
yeah I don't I'm not mm-hmm jesse
eisenberg no he's not for me either he's
in it but he's not for me uh he is I
mean I'm sure he's a great human but in
his Nathan for you that new experience
where [ __ ] go to relax
we've been watching Nathan for you
non-stop him it's like the best show in
the entire world
I think I've seen every episode yeah
proof okay hurry God my god it's okay
don't be scared little boy JK I'm a
ghost
the end Casper who's good start good
start those poses right told me to
rephrase it yeah it's okay don't be
scared little boy I'm like found Ted you
okay everything don't look at my hands
I'm not Oh however I said oh [ __ ] I'm
dead I've been dead this whole time I
don't know I don't know
no no I'm [ __ ] I just sleepy book
success yeah I just said oh no oh [ __ ]
and you're like I see dead people
alright good god dad dang dad died I'm
gonna go play the Snowman dad is that
[ __ ] jingle all the way
no that's you know but do it again say
it again um [ __ ] dad died want to go
play with a snowman dad I have no idea
Michael Keaton
it's called Jack Frost okay how in the
[ __ ] was I supposed to get on it's the
best movie literally of all time really
literally of all time from the person
snow game movie Big Daddy human son how
to shoot a hockey puck and nobody thinks
it's weird he goes to the hockey games
it is only allowed because he won't melt
and I was like oh it's that [ __ ] slow
man guy again
yes movie of all time okay well now I
know what we're doing tonight Jack from
watching Jack please can we watch it I
love Jack Frost oh yeah oh that's
relaxing I calmed me down
reduction is bit everywhere okay um I
have two more so okay I have a bunch
more okay why don't you fire off a
couple okay okay he's super vague you
wha I can understand what you're saying
does stuff the end toy sorry I can
understand what you're saying
the do it's the online video has been
advertising it for rosetta stone no I
don't know I can hear you you can talk
oh my god I can understand you so now I
can help you the dog is it a dog talking
is it is um is it a guinea pig talking
what stop it yeah those things job Oh
dr. Dooley yeah go on go okay right yeah
this is [ __ ] oh my god okay this
sounds like a horrible movie okay you
suck at your sport I do not [ __ ] a rich
person yells that their kids sister
doesn't suck at their sport the end
that's a shame of a description this
person is a girl could do it again okay
you suck at your sport
I do not [ __ ] a rich person yells that
their kids sister doesn't suck it there
oh I feel like I know this one is just
slipping my mind I actually have no idea
if you've ever seen this movie it's not
legal irreverent no do I hit yeah it's a
water sport this is this is a [ __ ]
movie about diving mm-hmm swimming
mm-hmm [ __ ] faith I just love yells
at their kids sister
[ __ ] a rich person wait they're kids
sister wouldn't that also be their other
kid mm-hmm
no it's her kid sister she yells at her
kid sister
her kid sister or her kids system her
kids sister her sister she yells at her
sister that's a kid you're making this
confusing get rid of the word kid that
caused a lot of games II know it's funny
if it's her kids sister it's also her
kid we it's not okay I get okay
don't know what oh wait a minute
wait I know this one I know this one
what no wait no I don't why don't you
try to figure out what the water sport
is it's not diving it's not swimming as
a water polo it's a ticket it's like an
ocean to you everything yeah no any
surface you don't know any girl surf
movies oh that girl crush one crush you
should've just said that that have you
never seen that no I know what it is
though oh now I know we're doing tonight
no yogi we already know we're doing a
nice Jack Frost what'd you do both how
about Jack Dawson Blue Crush weirdoes
whatever
man 1 just go to bed and or jump off the
balcony tonight sounds good right ready
for mine
yeah sure good middle-aged man falls in
love with high schooler has a moment of
clarity when he realized he's in love
with a high schooler as the Indiana
Jones no oh no she was in love with him
he was a teacher um I don't know
middle-aged married man mm-hmm
falls in love with high schoolers
American Beauty yes Goodman dope I
taught you to watch that I know it's
good movie that's my last one ended on
that and that's wrong but also not that
weak
I know you I have a few more okay ready
oh okay some of these are really [ __ ]
true okay thanks for teaching me stuff
dad dad no dad dies talks to dad in the
stars
knocks up a girl the end my god why does
everyone die zulan no that's good mm-hmm
no no harnesses you want talks to dad
and stars when he's this cartoon mm-hmm
Pocahontas is Hercules is it read it
again thanks for teaching me stuff dad
dad no dead Lion King yeah now that
first try good one first read okay you
ready look we're all gonna die unless
someone has a particular skill someone
has particular skill executed skill the
ender plane yeah well that movie I know
he's [ __ ] best okay
some dude actually turns a ho into a
housewife
the end
I know this one I'm not sure if you've
ever seen this movie though I definitely
know this plot [ __ ] I know the prop the
plot of a hooker falling in love with
someone that's not a hooker [ __ ] and
then pretty woman yeah yeah wait
beautiful girl
no pretty one mm-hmm that's for all you
office fans out there just had to get
women I'm sorry you laid it up be
peppered he jumped the al you what house
you in the mail FaceTime me that [ __ ]
okay dear I'm waiting on your hat you
you're the one who wrote down 100 answer
sir ready
I only have two more hundred set okay oh
man this is so [ __ ] troll kid people
that do one sport do another sport are
mediocre at it the end I mean that's
that's definitely also stuck on you just
saying kicking and screaming
what do you want a hint no yeah this
movie's really cool who runs yeah true
tell me that's not right I'm gonna do
one spark do another sport our video
gredin the end that's pretty good okay
this is the last one okay Oh a couple of
dudes realize hey you know it's not so
bad
anal Wow perk background yes I did not
see that but I'm glad I got it yeah it
sounds fun
somebody in this elevator is the devil
devil he is oh man um let us know in the
comments below what you guys thought of
this game it's really not any
participation of your own of course it
was very fun and we are these are the
types games where we can do part two if
we come up with another list
also not the green-screen make sure you
let us know if you if we get a green
screen what what suggestions you have
for the background in the podcast while
we pass the bearment just one giant
picture cerumen we can do that make sure
you check out our sponsors guys thank
you so much to our sponsors Boland
branch luxury bedding for affordable
prices check it out at Bowl and branch
comm enter products code Jenna Julian
for 20% off you get free shipping and 30
days risk-free Travis take it beautiful
blanket the sponsor me Eddie's go tiny
undies calm / Jenna Julian get some of
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever felt with her body 20% off go to
that URL with Valentine's Day get it for
your loved ones thank you to our
sponsors
thank you guys for listening and hanging
out with us for another podcast we
appreciate you that's how much we queue
we will see you guys next week on
another podcast Pam concern I mean